now this week we mark the 50th
anniversary of the first moon landing
the Apollo 11 mission and those that
followed allowed us to examine the
makeup of another celestial body 50
years later and with Earth's growing
appetite for raw materials the race is
on to find valuable minerals on the moon
and beyond just days ago the Japanese
space probe Hayabusa - landed on the
asteroid ryugu over 300 million
kilometres from Earth it's there to take
samples from beneath the surface and
bring them back home together with
France and Germany the Japanese space
agency aims to find out what the
asteroid is made of and if there might
be any valuable raw materials hidden
within the project is a world first with
multi sampling - landings and a
collection of under surface samples it's
awesome the US Space Agency NASA is also
examining an asteroid with its
osiris-rex probe it's taking samples of
the rock to find out what it's made of
and hopefully gain some insight into how
the earth was formed nASA has also been
looking for rare resources on the moon
for years the rugged crater and moon
scape could conceal valuable treasures
metals such as gold platinum iridium and
helium-3 gas have all been detected
there now it's trying to figure out how
to break down these raw materials and
transport them to earth
for more I'm joined by Professor Phil
bland the director of Curtin Space
Science and Technology Centre in Perth
Australia which is down under far away
from me a good to have you with us a
couple of years ago a space probe landed
on a comet now were chasing asteroids to
mine for minerals sounds like science
fiction how real is it I think it's
becoming much more real actually just so
over the last few years than I ever
thought it would be it's interesting
we're on both the Hayabusa and Osiris
Rex missions it's great to be part of
that there's there's private companies
involved in this now and also most major
space agencies and what do we hope to
find on an asteroid so that we can't
mine here on earth well it's I mean
there's a kind of a couple of flavours
here to this we can find as you said you
piece those heavy metals like iridium
and and and and and Rama
you know platinum and things like that
but in a way it's kind of the support
industries that we're interested in and
for those who need fuel and you need
water and we can get that from places
like ice on the moon all right but the
moon isn't right next door asteroids
certainly aren't all such missions are
very costly a bigger business
proposition is space mining then I think
so so NASA and Chinese Space Agency and
ISA all have a program to go back to the
moon over the next few years if you can
get fuel and water there versus carrying
it all the way that's a really big deal
so in terms of you know you save a huge
amount of money for every kilo you can
find there versus what you can bring
here so it's a huge support for those
missions and of course you I mean you
mentioned it there's a lot of
cooperation going on when it comes to
space missions between nations like the
United States and Europe once you get
there how do you determine the
miming rides on an extraterrestrial
object it's difficult enough here on
earth that's an excellent question
actually right now there are no mining
rights so so you can't legally make
money mining asteroids and bring it back
worse if you use that material to make
fuel I think that's okay but there's
some very old treaties in there and
those need to change before this becomes
an industry all right a professor field
lander the director of Curtin Space
Science and Technology Center in Perth
Australia thank you so much for your
time and your insights